having been in this town 11 some years
what do you think it is that prevents
someone or whatever it's someone that's
the hotshot that walks into a room
lights it up heads turn but they're not
going anywhere
what do you think that is it's a work
ethic is it just it whether it's radio
whether it's TV just someone that seems
like we have a potential talent it never
goes further than maybe means that
that's so whole like expect her that
Simon Cowell talks about I mean if they
truly light up the room and they truly
stand out and they're truly unique and
they're truly talented I believe that
those people more often than not succeed
now there are some people who think
they're unique and they're not they
think they're talented or they're
surrounded by people that tell them that
they are I think one of the things that
gets lost on talent is the business side
of it
now I don't want to speak from total
ignorance but I'm going to go out on a
limb here and say that people who are
making decisions they have an idea of
what they're trying to do and they have
already thought about how are they going
to market it I mean the business adapts
a perfect example you dig Twilight or
you take the Lord of the Rings and Harry
Potter a series of movies they basically
no longer just look at making a movie
they want to create a brand because
they've got a bigger plan they want to
create a marketing plan they want to
create t-shirts mugs lunchboxes whatever
but they've got a bigger picture they're
not going into it for one movie they
want to make three because it's cheaper
so there's a business side of it that I
think a lot of talent doesn't understand
and I think that's what comes into play
so if somebody is truly that talented
and takes that talent and then works it
it's not enough just to be talented in
general you still have to do the work
you still have to go do the showcases
learn theater I think that's almost also
a good one because you can't hide behind
take 2 take 3 take 4 yeah I've actually
they're now at the first time in front
of a live audience but in my opinion if
someone is truly that unique they'll
eventually get discovered but into the
person who is all of those things that
you listed and done and don't maybe they
can apply that same talent in a
different way I don't know in my case on
I do sales and all my radio talent have
helped me there I'll get to that
question later if you want but basically
you can sometimes find it your home is
what you thought and I don't know if
that makes sense
but you know it's kind of like the guy
that was creating the blue and
discovered you know wow if I stick this
to a back door a little piece of paper I
can make a great post-it note now if it
was designed to that originally to mount
an airplane wing to the fuselage we all
know that wasn't going to work but he
reapplied that same to that same thing
in another way and he created an amazing
product so I think the same applies for
people
you